Speaker 1: Hello,
and Mozel Tops.
It's your friends at
the Reno Sheriff's Department,
and this year
we're making a real effort
to respect all cultures.
All of them.
Even some of the Asian stuff.
Speaker 2: The Reno Sheriff's
Department
has always celebrated different
and diverse cultures,
as far as anyone knows.
Speaker 1: Oh sure.
This outreach
is not just part of some lawsuit
by those (expletive deleted)
at the ACLU, and that limousine
liberal like Tim Robbins,
Speaker 2: Expletive deleted.
[inaudible]
Speaker 1: But
a lot of folks wonder,
why is Jewish New Year
not the same
as white people New Year.
Speaker 2: Huh.
It's a gosh darn conundrum.
When do I say
Happy New
Year to Junior says
names of Jewish friends here.
Well, the Jewish calendar
operates on the moon,
like witches.
Speaker 1: For example.
Today is [Tevit] 5,779.
It's easier than you think,
once you know this
simple way to remember it.
Speaker 2: So, we all know
the Jewish year is called
Rosh Hashana or Yom Teruah,
and it starts on
the first day of Tishrei
and it's ends
on the second day of Tishrei,
which is the first month
of the Jewish civil year.
But not on the first day
of the ecclesiastical year,
which is the month of Nisan,
but don't panic.
You can always tell
what Jewish year
it is simply by adding
on 3,671 to the year.
Yep, it's that easy.
Speaker 1: Yep, it's that easy.
Speaker 2: So Happy New Year
everybody.
And to our Jewish friends,
Happy Monday night.
Speaker 1: [inaudible]
Speaker 2: Spit it out,
spit it out.
Speaker 1: No, Junior. I wasn't.
Speaker 2: Spit it out,
spit it out.
Speaker 1: Junior, I wasn't.
I'm not choking.
Speaker 2: It's okay, it's okay.
Does anybody know
the Heimlich maneuver?
Speaker 1: Ahhh. Hm, don't stop.
This feels good on the buns.
RENO_PSA_NYE_JewishNewYear_YT_FB
_320x240_1250_mp...